Fox News Alert North Korea just fired a
ballistic missile that flew over Japan
before crashing into the Pacific Ocean
the launch is yet another escalation to
the crisis and comes just days after the
United Nations passed a new set of
strict sanctions against North Korea for
details let's bring in Fox News chief
national correspondent and Henry
affectionately known as the six great
doesn't like me I like all of you the
bottom line is in the serious tense
situation here at the White House
tonight we've just gotten a statement
from the US Pacific Command in Hawaii
they are taking the lead on this the US
military declaring tonight that there
was no threat to North America or to
Guam important a note but also saying
they are monitoring this closely because
as you reported this missile flew over
Japan our key ally in the region
President Trump also was in fact briefed
on the situation by his chief of staff
general John Kelly also monitoring this
tonight is the defense secretary James
Madison remember he recently warned
North Korea it would be annihilated if
the US military used its war plans we're
hearing that as this missile was
launched madis and the head of US
nuclear forces they were talking to
reporters and the interview ended
abruptly with the general asking staff
did something happen what would happened
is the North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
launched an intermediate-range ballistic
missile he launched it eastward from
North Korea it flew over the territory
of northern Japan before landing in the
Pacific Ocean this missiles flight
distance is key it was about 2,300 miles
significant because that means Guam is
now in North Korea's range with a
missile like this it's also an
in-your-face move because as you noted
it comes just days after the u.s.
rallied the UN Security Council to pass
tough new sanctions against North Korea
led by ambassador nikki Haley there the
president warned in recent days that
even tougher sanctions may be coming and
next Tuesday the president himself will
be at the UN delivering his first-ever
speech to the General Assembly in New
York where North Korea of course
be front and center and tonight the US
Pacific Command is declaring that our
defense of Japan and South Korea is
quote ironclad and that the u.s. is
ready to quote defend ourselves and our
allies from any attack or provocation so
that from the US military tonight which
is watching all of this very closely
dinner all right thank you so much for
that report now for our top story
tonight President Trump causing all
sorts of controversy by saying he's
working on a deal with Democrats that
enhances border security and allows
dreamers illegal immigrants brought to
the US as children to stay in the
country
conservatives are upset that the deal
doesn't include funding for president
Trump's border wall but mr. Trump says
the wall still will eventually be built
the wall I wouldn't do anything we are
looking for extreme border security and
surveillance everything else we also
have to get the wall it doesn't have to
be here but they can't obstruct the wall
whether it's in a budget or something
else we're not looking at citizenship
we're not looking at happen
looking at allowing people to stay here
we're working with everybody Republican
everybody's on board Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer a Democrat doesn't
have any sympathy for those upset about
the wall funding in fact I listened to
Fox News this morning I'm starting to do
that to see what's going on over there
and they keep saying the president
promised a wall in the campaign yeah he
also promised that Mexico would pay for
it
where's Mexico they've said 12 times
they're not paying for it
that's not the promise he made all right
so all day we've been hearing about this
talking about it and one if you listen
closely Kimberly one of the things
President Trump said is with this
discussion you have the Democrats that
they couldn't struct something that
might be somewhere else not in the daca
bill but like in a budget and in fact
the house at base has passed border
funding it is in the budget proposal as
we speak so maybe that's what President
Trump was saying is that he can get the
doc a deal done and also get the wall
funded at the same time perhaps it was a
little bit of a heavy signal yeah right
I mean we go I got it so I think that's
what he's trying to do and look he's
trying to be a clever negotiator and a
businessman and say okay I'm gonna sit
down with them because I need a little
something you know from the left and
from the Democrats and this is something
that's important to them this is gonna
add value then they're gonna owe me he
needs to be able to reach across the
party lines like we've talked about to
get this support because he has very
like thin support to get something over
the hurdle legislatively as we've have
seen by the repeated attempts as it
relates to health care and other things
so immigration you mentioned early on
special report may be the one thing that
he's really able to you know jump across
get to the other side but on the flip
side a lot of his hardcore supporters
despite some more broad-based
Republicans work are not happy with this
they think that this is a side step away
and abandoning the principles that he
campaigned on and they tie the wall in
but he doesn't want them to lose faith
because he's saying listen to me I'm
gonna take care of the wall I still
intend to do it don't get distracted by
the machinations of you know Schumer and
Pelosi we're gonna do part of a deal
with them and I got a clever way to get
it in elsewhere I think that is
possibility what do you think Greg
well I think it's I was looking at
Twitter and I was watching people
burning their hats and I just think you
gotta relax that for the bass this is
your first if it's a young relationship
certain sometimes in the newlyweds get
in a big fight but it's too soon and
nothing really bad has happened yet and
I know there was a mention that there
was funding but now for the wall you
don't know that you know that funding
could go to the wall it could funding is
in the house budget yeah yeah yeah and
think about what docket docket is there
was no way he was gonna send them back
so instead of writing it off he turned
it into a something of value that he
used as a trade so basically traded it
away something that he really didn't
have to train so that was kind of a nice
little trick that you do it's kind of
like when a kid for his birthday takes
his dad to the store and he wants these
two hundred dollar pair of shoes but he
knows his dad doesn't want to pay that
so he points at the twelve hundred
dollar bike and the dad goes huh you're
not getting that and he goes well how
about these shoes and the kid their dad
goes yeah it's a little something a
smart kid does there's a couple other
things number one he show us to make a
deal if he cuts chain migration if he
gets a verified if you get somebody but
builds a wall or part of a wall or
something of a wall it's a pretty good
deal but the bigger thing is and what he
did the big picture the idea of building
the wall created a shift in the
conversation I'm not saying he created
the conversation immigration we were
talking about on the five for five years
that's where he got a lot of it but he
forced the media to confront an entire
population who were unhappy about about
the border that's what he did
we didn't do that he did that yeah it
also helped him win the the build the
wall as a meaning which is enhanced
border protection was a was one of the
three legs of that table which was law
you know of the table of law and order
it was it was immigration police and
national security that's what got him in
so this the big picture it got him a win
created a shift in the conversation if
he could do this deal he's a winner I
could I agree that it's a combination
Jesse of these things of border security
more enforcement but I do think he's
when he said I'm going to build a wall
he described it and how it was going to
look and all
the chance that all the rallies was
build the wall and who's gonna pay for
it Mexico's gonna pay for it and that
was the big rallying cry so I couldn't
see why some people would be upset
even though they probably still are
going to support him yeah if the wall
doesn't get built waters world is not
going to be happy I think a lot of the
base is going to be very displeased that
was the centerpiece of his campaign it
wasn't just the metaphor it was and you
know what the wall is a metaphor too
because if you can't get that done and
you ran on that and you're a builder and
that's your major policy initiative then
what have you got to run on and for
reelection
if there's no wall so that has to be
done the dock a deal the base freaking
out a little bit about that I understand
that it's not amnesty though he's not
delivering a pathway to citizenship if
there is amnesty for the dreamers people
are gonna have a hard time stomaching
that I support daca but if they cut in
line and they're delivered amnesty I'm
gonna have a hard time dealing with that
I think a lot of people are too I think
what Nancy and Ron Chuck did was they
came out and they spun the dinner and
put the President on the defensive while
he was in Florida today always want to
be the first to define your meeting
that's right in this swamp run then this
rule number one of the swamp get out of
the meeting go to the microphones first
and that's what they did they said we
have a deal on daca and the border wall
funding is off the table the President
had to come out and say there is no deal
and we're gonna fund the wall later I
understand what he's doing with the wall
funding by not linking it to daca
because no Democrat is gonna vote to
fund the wall I just don't see it it's
an invitation and a bunch of people
Brian married only there and that's
going to be hard because if you're a
Democrat and you vote to fund the border
wall your opponent primaries you and
says you know congressman so-and-so
Democrat voted to fund the racist border
wall that Trump wants you're done in
that primary so I don't think there's a
chance it has to come in a big like
omnibus bill and a cliff-hanging debt
ceiling situation on Christmas Eve
that's the only way it's a phony key
sneak-attack what do you think from the
Democrats perspective well I think the
Democrats first of all I think they got
a good deal here I mean they they're
working with the president he wants to
work with them I don't know if you saw
this but Chuck Schumer's
on the floor talking and gets picked up
on a hot mic and he says basically he
likes us it's like you know she likes me
anyway he likes us and that you've got
to take a step left and a step right
otherwise you get boxed in says Schumer
I think that right now though the
reality is I don't give much credence to
the idea that the wall is funded in
anybody's budget I don't think that's
mainly going to happen and at the moment
it may down the road I could be wrong
but I think what I gave credence to is
the idea that Steve King says this is
gonna blow up his president Trump's base
or Ann Coulter says well who doesn't
want Trump impeached at this point cuz
she's now knows that the left wants him
out she wants it not because he's not
living up to the promise that Jesse
articulated what interests me is the
actual legislation on the floor
Democrats are proposing a vote on the
DREAM Act so that's what they're putting
in front of Trump Republicans on the
other half other hand have something
called recognizing America's children
now what's the big difference the big
difference is that the DREAM Act will
give you conditional residency which is
a pathway to citizenship what about the
Republican plan you have to apply for
that conditional residency but it's
still a pathway to citizenship so you
can imagine Steve Bannon at Breitbart
just saying this is you know a free pass
this amnesty
this is and the president said on tape
today no way amnesty we haven't talked
about amnesty that way so hearing that
is troubling I think it is crummy but I
will say this I was surprised to read
that mark Meadows who's head of the
freedom caucus said we don't have to
vote on a wall for a wall say he's like
he wasn't heavily invested I know that
Senator McConnell of a Senate majority
not heavily invest Paul Ryan not heavily
invested they don't even want to vote on
the thing right all right what would you
said on the campaign instead of building
a wall what would have been your what
would have been war I mean as a promise
you know what I mean I'd lock her own
borders well do you think I do but
everybody says strong borders what white
the reason why he won is that he didn't
say strong borders or enhanced border
security
he said build a wall that could mean all
of those things that could mean all
those things but he said it that way
because it resonated you think that's
what he really meant when he talked to
ya about actual physical
auction of the wall they actually have
they have called an contractors to come
in and give plans for what that I think
that's cool structure with yeah yeah I
think I think I think it saying it but
he didn't mean no no I'm shake because
no your your you guys are saying that he
promised this and people are gonna be
upset I'm saying that it's a it was a
visual promise for example in a fairy
tale
you say they lived happily ever after
you don't say they lived to the age of
83 after a series of debilitating
illnesses you say something that is
visual and catches you and then you
worry about it later I think here's how
I know Chuck's heavily invested in
building the wall because I looked at
the prototypes these eight contracts one
of the requirements is has to be
aesthetically pleasing from the American
side you know Trump wants it to be
aesthetically prison and what's the
quote who's complaining no one